[Music]
okay everybody I am so thrilled today
because I am joined by Taryn Edgerton
AKA Jimmy Keane in the new Apple TV plus
series Blackbird that comes out this
Friday how you doing today Taryn hey man
I'm really good thank you it's good to
speak with you yeah man really good to
speak with you and I absolutely love
this show I'm excited for people to see
it and what's interesting is it's
awesome that you're always doing roles
that are based off real life people is
that something you gravitate towards is
there something specifically you love
about doing that I mean not
self-consciously it's a funny thing I've
not really thought about it but you are
the first person to mention it these
past couple of days I I don't know why
it is there's definitely a kind of an
atmosphere that comes with knowing a
story is true and maybe I'm drawn to
characters that I feel
I don't know really lived and breathed I
don't know I really don't know now but
speaking of that though is there like a
pressure in your head when there's a
person that you're playing is still
alive and they're a producer on the show
is that always in the back of your mind
or you can you kind of no I think I
think if that gets in the back of your
mind you're you're screwed I keep it way
out of my mind because it would get in
the way of me doing my job but you know
I think if I think if you if you're in I
feel like I like performances where
someone doesn't always look great
um but of course you know a lot of
people would want a a performance of
their life for them to look pretty great
so I mean I don't know it would get him
I think it would get in my way if I
became too fixated on it so what's
interesting though is that you always
pull it off and you're really getting
known for being so good at transforming
into different roles so what do you
think was the most you had to transform
for this part of Jimmy Keane and
yourself
well I think that you know what Dennis
is examining with the show is this idea
of toxic masculinity and the character
of Jimmy Keane is
uh I think kind of Prides himself on his
alpha male hyper masculinity and I don't
think that
people would
um would raise their eyebrows if I
describe myself as being anything like
that so you know I
um I think for me I I knew that I wanted
to do something to to kind of really
ground myself and and actually get a bit
bigger as well so I you know I did lots
of gym time and and thought a lot about
the kind of the very muscular
physicality of who my Jimmy Keane was
um so yeah I trained for a few months
before we started shooting and alongside
the shoot uh just to kind of feel like a
guy who's
earthed and into himself and can handle
himself but is also kind of
you know got a bit of vanity to him as
well yeah and it's awesome because all
that shows on the screen and I think
that's what people excited about seeing
you is like what is he going to do next
who is he going to become next and it's
exciting and you crush it here and oh
also oh no problem and it's what's great
too is watching you and Paul Walter
Hauser work together on set to treat to
see you guys together now for these
scenes though before this project even
did you guys meet beforehand or is it
better for you not to know him and then
just kind of meet on set how did you
kind of approach that no when we were
both given the roles we began a kind of
you know text correspondence I I he was
I'm not sure where he was in the States
but I was in the UK I'd been filming
another thing prior to this
um and you know when we when we did
finally meet we we hit it off
immediately you know we had a really
really really great time together and I
think that's important because there is
that you know it's a dark part of the
story but even though Jimmy is repulsed
by Larry they do connect you know and
it's important that they have a a bond
of sorts
um and Paul and I had no trouble finding
that
so knowing that you guys have that Bond
when you're actually on set though do
you both stay in character during answer
like when the scenes break or are you
able to tap in and out not really we tap
we tap in and out I mean I think
sometimes a scene can be
be of a kind of level of complexity or
emotional charge where it can feel
difficult to you know finish a take and
then start texting or talking about what
you're going to have for your dinner
later so you know sometimes
you just sit and be present with each
other and kind of stay in the zone
that's often a thing
um but to be totally honest with me and
Paul like a lot of the time we were
doing stuff to kind of clear the air and
kind of you know cleanse the energy by
singing stupid songs and making each
other laugh
um uh and you know if you work with Paul
Walter Hauser you will laugh that guy is
funny
um but yeah he was a treat to work with
and and I think you know it's very
exciting to watch an actor like Paul who
you probably know best for his comedic
work and see him come and do a role like
this and knock it out the park is super
exciting oh yeah and you guys have this
great chemistry together too especially
when it's that difficult type of
chemistry where it's a very dark rolly
yeah you know so really awesome and it's
awesome too I think people get excited
today when they see a movie star
you know doing a TV series what was it
about doing a TV series that maybe you
liked better than doing per se a movie
well I think you know it's if a
character's interesting to play it's
great to be able to play them for a for
a longer period of time you know and and
I think with with that kind of limited
series format you can really develop the
richness of a character in a way that
I'm just not sure you can with
um with films you know it's it's I think
that's the reason when people talk about
the best characters of all time it's
quite often more you know
the Walter whites or the Tony Sopranos
than it is any of the kind of archetypal
great movie characters because you it's
more of a study so by virtue of the fact
a limited series is three times the
length of a movie you it feels like more
of a study of a character and and that's
so satisfying for an actor you know yeah
and I think people will say too that
it's a week to week release so like we
can really invest like a month or two
into this character yeah I think that's
great too you know I think for a time
with these streaming shows there was
there was a few things that were kind of
dumped in one go and that's great if you
love binging a show but it's it's kind
of like spending all your chips in one
go whereas for a show like this which is
all about suspense I think it's much
better that we do it over a period of
weeks yeah I agree with that and uh I
also Wonder Too Your executive producing
on this did that bring any more stress
to you or was it something excited about
no no stress
um well I'm in the show you know making
any
movie or TV show is always pretty
stressful
um no the the having the chance to be
privy to some conversations that weren't
just about my role as an actor you know
to be involved with discussions around
directors and
um you know the casting of other roles
was all Dennis the one role that I was
involved with casting was was Larry
um and that was you know new territory
for me and and you know Dennis had these
perfect scripts so it's not like there
were conversations around script
decisions but just to be able to have
conversations with him knowing what he's
thinking knowing about you know what
he's thinking of doing with music and
and other Personnel decisions with you
know Natalie Kingston the
cinematographer and all of that was very
exciting to me you know uh it's nice to
be to feel like you're part of the
filmmaking as well as part of the acting
of the lead role yeah that's awesome
it's cool to see you expanding and doing
more stuff like that it's exciting and I
also had to ask too I mean gotta bring
up the amazing performance you did as
Elton and was winning the Golden Globe
so far the highlight of your crew would
you say and are you praying to that
thing every morning you got that like in
the shrine uh I I couldn't my apartment
um uh no Shrine um
uh like uh yes it you know it was it the
Highlight I don't know if it was it was
a great moment and you know I think
it felt like a really
um
it felt like quite a nice moment to kind
of end what had been a really long
journey with rocket man because more
than anything else I'd done I I it was
two years of my life because of all the
music and then the promoting of it was a
kind of extended process as well
um but you know the you know the best
moment of my career I don't know really
you know the best moment of my career
was probably when we screened it at can
and that was that when it went and and
we had a sense that people were really
loved it that that was that was that was
up there that probably more that than
the Globes although man the gloves was a
great night yeah yeah and that's
exciting I think what's going to excite
people is just gonna be another project
they're gonna see Blackbird where
they'll be clapping in their home at
least it might not be a Cairns but
they'll be here and watching loving it
so just know that yeah so Taryn thank
you for joining me today I really
appreciate it and uh watch him kill it
in Blackboard this Friday on Apple TV
plus the first few episodes come out now
and then it'll be week to week have a
great one Taryn thanks so much this was
a really nice chat thank you